hi my name is Luke Siciliano and I'm a
web
developer this is going to be a
four-part discussion on how you can make
money as a freelancer this is a really
important topic to talk about because a
lot of people who are just finishing
free code camp are wondering what am I
going to do now I finish the certificate
program am I going to go out in three
lanced am I going to get a job if I'm
going to start a business it's
understandable that people have been so
focused on their education that now they
might be a little nervous about
wondering what they're gonna do with
that education so in this discussion
we're going to look at the option of
being a freelance developer okay now
we're going to look at four things
number one is should you be a freelancer
at all because obviously if freelance
work isn't a good fit for you personally
then you don't need to know anything
else about it number two we're going to
look at how to make yourself stand out
from other freelance developers number
three is going to be how to sell your
services because selling is something a
lot of people just aren't comfortable
with and number four after we've talked
about how to sell your services we'll
talk about where to take those
salesmanship skills and to sell your
services and who you're gonna how who
you're going to reach out to how you're
going to reach out to them so on and so
forth and I think after getting over
going over those four things you'll have
a basic understanding of do I want to be
a freelancer and if so this is a good
here's how I'm gonna go down that path
and earn a living doing it well let's
start with the most important question
and that is should you be a freelance
developer at all because obviously if
you don't have the personality type for
it then you don't need any of the other
information right when asking the
question should I be a freelance
developer you really got to break that
question down into two parts number one
is a good fit for your personality and
number two can you make money doing it
because if it's not a good fit for you
then you're probably destined to fail at
it and if it is a good fit for you then
you're probably a good chance of
succeeding at it the second part of that
can you make money doing it is really
important right because if you can't
make a living doing this why would you
do it so let's start with the question
of should you and look at your
personality type and say are you good
fit for freelance work when you're
saying am i a good fit for freelance
work you really
need to ask yourself are you a social
self-motivated individual or you someone
who needs structure provided to you
here's what I mean by that when you're
doing freelance work you're going to
really be your own self regulating boss
you're gonna be the one to make sure
that you start work at a certain time
every day that you work through a
certain time every day a lot of times
you're gonna be working from home so you
need to be able to filter out
distractions you need to be able to
impose deadlines upon yourself and have
a certain sense of discipline so if
you're very self-motivated and self
disciplined then freelance work might be
a good fit for you because no one's
gonna be imposing that structure on you
all right now if you're someone who
needs a certain structure in your life
in other words you need a boss telling
you you have to beat your desk by 8:30
every morning you need to be told when
assignments are due by because if you're
not told when they're due by you might
just put them off put them off put them
off if you're easily distracted you're
someone who is probably I need that
structure provided for you by an
employer a lot of times when you're a
freelancer for example you're going to
be working at home and you know you're
working at home the doorbell rings you
answer it sign for your package from
Amazon and now you're distracted you
can't get yourself back to work if
that's your personality type then you
need structure provided for you in other
words you need a boss you need that
company that's going to tell you here's
when things are due here's when to be
here so on so forth and if that's your
personality type you're probably better
off being an employee versus the person
who's self-motivated and self
disciplined who is probably better off
being a freelance developer and being
their own boss now if you're someone who
needs that structure provided for you
there's nothing wrong with that there
are a lot of really successful people in
the world who aren't self employed
aren't freelancers and they just need to
work within a structure but when they're
in that environment they really excel at
it so if this isn't for you and you're
saying well I need structure don't feel
bad about that it just means that
freelance work is right for you it means
you should probably be working for
somebody instead that being said if
you're that self-motivated individual
you would probably be frustrated working
in a really structured job because you
know you don't need someone telling you
when to get things done and so on so for
if you can work independently and people
that can work independently tend to
Excel a little bit more in environments
where they're their own boss
so really ask yourself are you a
self-motivated self disciplined
individual or do you need structure
provided for you if it's the former
freelance work is probably a good fit
for you now the next question is
assuming I have the personality type to
be a freelance developer can I make
money doing this because again need to
make a living right gotta pay the bills
I would answer yes you can make money as
a freelance developer and I would
actually argue that for freelancers
there's a market out there of twenty one
point six billion dollars you can tap
into it's a lot of numbers I'm gonna say
again twenty one point six billion I
would have written out all the zeros but
I'm quite lazy and I don't like to write
that much how do I come up with this
number that there's a twenty one almost
twenty two billion dollar market for you
to tap into I'll break this down there's
roughly twenty four million small
businesses in the United States I that
I'm talking about the local bakery local
pizza shop local bar local hair salon
local fitness studio you name it just
start naming businesses all right
roughly twenty four million of them
roughly thirty percent twenty nine
percent but will rounded up to thirty
roughly thirty percent of those small
businesses in 2017 either don't have a
website or have one that is drastically
out-of-date it might not be
mobile-friendly something of that nature
may sound inconceivable to us as tech
people that how can thirty percent of
small businesses not have a website it's
true
so if thirty percent of small businesses
need web work done and there's 24
million small businesses that's 7.2
million small businesses in the country
that need that kind of work now let's
say you would charge the average small
business $3,000 for any website that's
probably a really low number but for the
purpose of this discussion let's go with
it
if you charge $3,000 for
the average website and there's 7.2
million small businesses that need that
service 7.2 million times $3,000 is 21
billion 600 million so that's how I come
up with the number that there's a market
out there of 21 billion 600 million
dollars out there for you to cap in tap
into last time I checked that's a lot of
money okay and if you do some of the
things we're going to talk about a
little later in this video I think you
can tap into this effectively so that
being said there's a big market you can
make a lot of money this number probably
actually underestimates the opportunity
out there and the reason I say that is
that's assuming you're just building a
relatively cheap website for those small
businesses what if you're building a
website for the local pizza pizza shop
and they want a mobile app or something
on top of it you might charge them more
than the $3,000 so big market you can
make a lot of money doing this so on the
question of should you be a freelancer
ask yourself are you self-motivated or
do you need structure provided for you
if you're a self-motivated individual
this is for you if you need the
structure that job provides not for you
can you make money doing this
make a lot of money doing this so ask
yourself those questions look at it in
those terms and say is this for me if it
is keep on watching in the next part of
the video we're going to talk about how
to make yourself stand out from other
freelance developers
okay we're back for part two in our
discussion of how to make money as a
freelance developer and since you're
still watching that means you've decided
that freelancing is potentially for you
and you want to know how to go about
building a business as a freelancer so
in this part of the video we're going to
talk about how to make your services
stand out a little bit against those of
other freelancers so you can make a good
living and not just be part of the pack
and then we'll go on to how to sell your
services properly and you'll see that
this part of the video will wrap into
the next part in a little bit but this
has some important discussions that we
need to have before we talk about how to
actually sell your services and since
you've already watched the first part of
the video you have figured out my
handwriting is terrible
good a lot of things writing is not one
of them
sorry so let's talk about how to make
yourself stand out from other developers
though now this is an important topic to
have a discussion on the reason for that
is I feel there's a very big disconnect
between the development community and
the people who would consume the
services of the developers mainly small
businesses here's why I say there's a
disconnect as I said in as I said in the
last part of my video there's roughly
thirty percent of small businesses don't
have a quality website in 2017 so this
is those businesses right here if you go
onto google and just do a search in your
local city for you know name of my city
website builder you will find an
abundance of people ready to build
websites for these businesses just in
your town okay so if you've got this
huge pool of potential customers and
you've got this abundance of labor ready
to do the work that these people need
you have to ask why isn't this work
getting done right because again lots of
work lots of people to do it but somehow
these services aren't getting sold in
other words there is a disconnect these
developers are not connecting with these
potential customers in a way that makes
these potential customers say I want to
buy that service so if you really want
to make yourself stand out as
freelancer you've got to bridge this gap
otherwise you're just gonna be one of
these developers stuck over here
wondering why can't I get this business
why can't I get this business so let's
really fast look at how you're gonna
bridge this and the biggest step to
bridging that and I'll explain what I
mean by this but it's to understand that
once you become a freelancer you're not
a developer you're not a coder you're
not a programmer you're not an app
builder you're not oh whatever you want
to call itself you are a problem solver
okay you're a problem solver and here's
what I mean by that let's say I'm the
potential small business customer I'm a
local pizza shop I don't have a website
I want a website so that potential
customers can order food online
I want a website so that someone who's
never been to my pizza shop before can
look at photos of my dining room see how
nice it is see how nice my bar is when
they see those pictures maybe they'll
come into my restaurant right that's all
I care about
I care about getting those needs met and
that's it but here when I'm sitting here
with those needs
the average developer sitting over here
going I'll build your website using the
latest CMS I will build your website
writing my own HTML
I know CSS I know PHP I'm really good
with JavaScript so on so forth this
person this small business owner doesn't
even know what any of that stuff means
first of all and when someone's going I
use a CMS or I will write it in HTML
instead using a CMS this person over
here is gonna say well okay but explain
to me how that solves my problem all
right
so really these developers are talking a
they're talking past the potential
customers and they're talking over the
heads of the potential customers okay so
what you need to do is identify the
problems of that small business let's
stick with the pizza shop example that's
where the developer should say tell me a
little bit about your needs I would like
a website okay and then the developer
can ask questions understand what it is
that the customer is trying to get from
that website and then the developer can
propose solutions to meet those problems
so in other words it's important for the
developer to be an active listener and
then propose a solution based on that
active listening this is a really big
contrast to the experience you'll have
if you go onto Google and as I said look
for developers in your local area
because again you'll see the local
developer who's got his own website
talks about his coding skills again if
you're the small business owner all that
talk about coding skills doesn't talk
about meeting your problems in meeting
your needs when they smile
businessperson talks that developer on
the phone that developer a lot of times
it's just going to talk about code and
technical jargon that a small business
owners understand again everything I'm a
small business owner right here
everything I've just heard from that guy
isn't speaking to my needs so I'm
probably gonna call somebody else so
what you really need to do is understand
you're not a coder you're a problem
solver you need to make an important
part of your job identifying the
problems of the customer and then
proposing a solution to meet those
problems if you do that you bridge this
disconnect and while all these
developers are stuck over here wondering
how they get business you're crossing
this bridge and you're tapping into
these roughly 7.2 million small
businesses that don't have a website or
need a website in 2017 and that's how
you're gonna make a lot of money now
this concept is going to get wrapped a
little bit into the next part of our
discussion on how to best sell your
services it's very very important that
you recognize that there's this
disconnect out there between the
development community and the people
that need those services and that you
can bridge that disconnect by making
yourself a problem solver understand
these things and you'll really make
yourself stand out so all that being
said let's apply some of this to how to
sell your services
okay we're back for part three in our
video discussion on how to make money as
a freelance developer we just looked at
how to make yourself stand out a little
bit from the crowd and how to really
make yourself a good business person as
opposed to a lot of the freelancers that
are just kind of skating by and that is
by understanding and solving your
customers problems as opposed to wanting
to just say I'm a developer I write code
alright making yourself a problem
solvers how you make yourself stand out
in this part of the video we're going to
talk about how to sell your services
which is something a lot of people
aren't comfortable with and you're going
to see what we just talked about about
being a problem solver really rolls into
selling your services effectively before
we talk about how to sell your services
there's one thing I want to get out of
the way and that is that I understand a
lot of people aren't comfortable selling
a lot of people aren't comfortable
talking about themselves talking up
their services dealing with other people
in a sales kind of way well two things
to that number one is some people this
comes naturally to some people it
doesn't but everybody can be good at it
sales are something that if you're
willing to get outside of your comfort
zone a little bit and work on it and
practice and give it an effort you can
get good at it even if you're not
necessarily the most comfortable with it
right now
so the selling your services is
something you can do I can't stress that
enough you can sell your services even
if you feel uncomfortable with it the
second thing I want to mention real fast
is that you don't have a choice if you
want to be a freelance developer if
you're not good at selling your services
or I should say if you don't make an
effort at being good at selling your
services you're going to go broke
because you're not going to have any
customers ok so again you can do this
you can sell trust me I've seen lots of
people who initially were uncomfortable
selling that over time and do me anytime
got good at it
so all that being said let's talk about
how to go about selling your services
which is something a lot of people are
really unsure of how to do and this
really comes down to
a couple of things really the initial
meeting with a potential customer will
talk about that we'll talk about putting
together a proposal for that potential
customer and we'll talk about closing
that deal and a lot of times this will
all essentially be within one
conversation so you know might span a
couple but typically you're looking at
one so the first thing is the initial
meeting this might be a meeting it
wherever you're working if you have an
office a lot of times you gonna be
working on this will probably be over
the telephone potential customers going
to call you this is your chance to make
yourself a problem solver like we just
talked about we're gonna stick with the
local pizza shop on our example example
and you've got to use this initial
contact with a potential client to
identify the potential clients problem
so you can help the client understand
how you're going to solve those problems
so let's say again I'm a local pizza
shop owner I call you your web developer
typical web developer in my experience
the typical web developer might say
something along the lines of okay what
kind of business is it okay it's a pizza
shop do you need online ordering okay do
you need online reservations okay
anything else about your business all
right well let me give you a quote well
that doesn't really do a lot to
understand the customers business if you
take the steps to understand the
customers business you can identify the
problems and by identifying the problems
you do a lot better so let's look at how
this should go okay the developers
talking to the pizza shop owner okay
you're a pizza shop owner are you dying
in only or you carryout only or do you
have a dine in business okay you have a
significant dining business so where is
your customer base is it just a local
neighborhood around you oh you're right
by a university as well so you sell with
a lot of college sell them a lot of
college kids and not just you know like
residential areas okay
would your customers prefer to order
online is that something you've
experimented with do you have a bar in
your establishment or is it just a pizza
shop itself what are your goals what are
your goals as a you know business do you
want to grow to multiple locations so on
and so forth by asking those kinds of
questions you really start to understand
what it is this business wants to
accomplish right oh you're a business
you have a significant business with a
significant dying in business as well as
a takeout business we're going to need a
photo gallery that showcases showcases
your dining in experience we might wanna
get some professional photographs taken
that shown people eating having a good
time feature the waitstaff so on so
forth oh you've got a bar you know we
should make sure we feature the bar as
well you are right by a college well you
know a lot of younger people are
probably going to prefer to order online
so we need to make sure we include
online ordering on there do you offer
any college specials we should probably
have a tab on the website that talks
about your specials for delivery to the
to the kids at school by saying those
kinds of things you really identify
specifics about this business that might
make it a little different from another
pizza shop so in other words you have
identified the customers problem so you
can do all this in the initial meeting
right use the initial meeting learn
about the business that initial business
help or that initial meeting and
learning about the business helps you
identify the business's problems you can
then put together a proposal to solve
those problems that proposal will be a
website that includes all the types of
features I just mentioned and then you
close this sale by explaining to the
person okay I'm going to build you a
website here's what it's going to
include and here's how it including
those features will solve your problems
are you interested in purchasing that
versus okay I'll build your website
here's how much it's gonna cost you
wanted you know so right when you think
about it the proposal that includes
problem solving is going to sound a lot
more effective now a lot of times this
will all be during one conversation and
the person will say good send me a
contract
have to have a couple of conversations
with the person but the idea of using
the initial meeting to identify problems
putting together a proposal that solves
those problems and then closing by
explaining how the proposal solves those
problems is how you connect with your
potential customers and sell to your
potential customers in a way that's much
different than a lot of other developers
and I think you'll see really good
results with this we could easily do a
30 hour course just on selling alone but
this is the initial framework that you
need to focus on get information to
identify problems but the other proposal
solves those problems explain that
problem-solving to the customer couple
of things I want to say on these just to
make a few fast points when you're
getting ready for that initial meeting
make sure you're in an appropriate venue
for it like I said a lot of times those
initial meetings are gonna be someone
just calling you on your phone I've seen
instances where a developer is driving
down the road in their car and their
business number rings and they answer it
and they're trying to us they're
essentially trying to do a sales call
with a small business person while
they're driving down the road I mean
come on and think about that for a
minute if you're driving down the road
trying to talk to a customer you're not
taking any notes you're supposed to be
paying attention to the road so you're
only halfway paying attention to the
potential customer right you're not
really in a position to have the kind of
meaningful conversation you need to have
to be able to identify that customers
problems and discuss them intelligently
so you're almost certainly going to lose
that sale you'd be much better off in
that instance to just let the call go to
voicemail maybe the person will leave a
voicemail maybe they won't but if they
do leave a voicemail you can call them
back when you're in a better environment
to handle that phone call and in you
have a good chance of closing that sale
versus the developer who takes a call
while they're driving down the road and
almost certainly loses the sale that
being said this kind of gets back to the
first part of our video about being self
motivated if it's during business hours
you know make sure you're spending a lot
of your day in places where you can take
these kinds of phone calls don't be dick
out driving around during business hours
no more than you have to and so on so
forth so setting yourself up to be able
to take a phone call as silly as that
sounds is something a lot of developers
strike out at and by making yourself
available and making sure you're in an
appropriate setting to do these initial
meetings usually over the phone you put
yourself ahead when you're putting
together that proposal in writing or
first-first you're gonna put it together
orally and explain it to the client and
you'll put something together for them
in writing when you put it together and
explain here's what I propose it's very
important that you explain it in a way
the clients going to understand don't
speak technical jargon to them more than
you need to because the clients aren't
going to understand most of that stuff
when you're putting the proposal
together into writing and a contract
it's very important you spell out
specifically what you are going to do
for that customer otherwise you put
yourself at risk of a disagreement over
what you were going to do and not going
to do so make sure the written proposal
has your entire scope of work in it last
thing is again when you're closing with
that person start with okay here are the
problems I've identified here's what I'm
going to do here's how that will fix
those problems again we can do a 30-hour
course on selling go about things in
this way and you will be a much better
seller of your services than most of
your competition initial meeting
identifies problems proposal is where
you put together the list of things
you're going to do to solve those
problems closing is when you explain to
the customer how that proposal is going
to solve the problems you've identified
in the next part of our video we're
going to talk about where to sell your
services now that you've figured out how
to do it
okay so it just talked about where to
sell your services as a freelance
developer now it's important that we
talk about where to sell those services
because obviously you gotta have a way
to connect with potential customers and
put the selling skills we just talked
about to use so let's look at some
effective ways for you to go out and
drum up business as a freelancer and
really I'm going to talk about three
sources the first is good old-fashioned
networking second one is using
third-party services and the third
option is going to be utilizing your own
website to go out and get business so
let's look at each of these interns
networking going to networking functions
is just what it sounds like here is one
thing I would suggest to that though to
that point is I see a lot of developers
who go out to networking functions as a
way of trying to get business and most
of the people as a networking event are
other developers so in other words it's
developers out talking to developers
the idea being I am a developer I go to
one of these functions I meet somebody
else there's a job offer that they're
not interested in or that they want to
outsource and maybe they'll give it to
me you can get some work doing this
don't get me wrong there are ways to or
you this is a way to get some business I
should say that being said I don't think
it's an effective way to go out and
network what you want to do to drum up
business this way that really stands out
from other developers and it's just more
effective is to go to networking events
where the people there aren't other
developers the people there are your
potential customers or they know your
potential customers so examples would be
going to networking events where you're
talking to very small business owners
from a wide range of fields and so on so
forth and you're the only developer in
the room right I mean isn't that a lot
better way to meet potential people that
might want your services a really good
place for doing this what I just
mentioned is a group called BNI Business
Network international there's going to
be a link
in the description below what BNI is is
it's a national organization and most
cities have multiple chapters you want
to join a chapter that's as close to you
as possible
and what they do is they have exclusive
spots for different fields so if you're
the software developer in your chapter
you're going to be the only software
developer in that chapter there will
also be four just as examples maybe a
real-estate agent in that chapter a
chiropractor a lawyer a general
contractor a hair salon owner and so on
and so forth and the idea of BNI is that
everyone in that room is opening up
their address book to you and you're
opening up your address book to them so
in other words if I'm the lawyer in the
BNI chapter and during my journeys I
Nene I come across a business owner who
needs development work I will refer them
to you as a developer and then if you
doing during your journeys come across
somebody that needs car maintenance you
might refer them to the auto mechanic
that's in the BNI group so in other
words every once open their address
books up to one another and because
everyone in those groups are small
business owners or is a good chance they
know other small business owners BNI can
be a really good place to network and
meet small business owners who might
need your services but also who might
also refer you business from people they
know so don't just go to networking
events where you're just sitting around
talking to other developers hoping to
get some business out of it get out
there and talk to the community at large
and BNI is a great way to do that in the
business community second option would
be to use third party services by this I
mean services such as Fiverr thumbtack
these are essentially websites where
you're probably familiar with them where
you go on thumbtack for example you fill
out a profile you profile you say you're
a developer and then somebody who needs
development services might go on to felt
like a website
might go on to thumbtack and put out an
offer saying I want a developer to do
this and then you can bid on that work
fibers works a little differently but
it's generally the same concepts in
other words it's a third party website
that matches the providers of services
with consumers of services the upside of
doing a third party platform like fiber
or thumbtack is that those platforms get
a lot of traffic I mean a lot there are
a lot of people who anytime they need
something they go to Fiverr they go to
thumbtack so for example if I'm the
small local pizza shop owner and every
time I need some repairs done inside my
restaurant I call a contractor off the
thumbtack or anytime I need something
else done I call somebody off the
thumbtack they're probably going to do
the exact same thing when they want a
website built so UNTAC by ever those
kinds of sites are a very good way to
put you into connection with a lot of
potential customers the downside of
these kinds of services are that a you
tend to be doing the work at a rate
lower than what you would prefer to
charge it's just the nature of fiber and
thumbtack in these third party platforms
is that you tend to do the work in a bit
of a discount so a website you might
normally charge $3,000 for you might
charge two thousand dollars or even
$1500 or even $1,000 for it if you're
doing it on one of these websites and
you have to pay to get the lead on top
of it so you're looking at much tighter
profit margins that being said there's
an abundance of work to go out there and
get so ups and downs to that third
option would be to build up your own
website and promote it when you build up
your website you want to do it in a way
that I talked about in the second part
of our video and build your website in a
way that tells potential customers I am
going to listen to your problems and
help you solve them when you're
promoting your website for most people
the most effective way to do that is
going to be to utilize a pay-per-click
program like Google Adwords you know
we're all familiar about those
those paid paid ads you see at the top
of Google and Bing outside of doing this
is it's your website so you're not
discounting your work you know the
website that you might build for a
thousand dollars for someone finding you
on Fiverr thumbtack you'll charge the
full three thousand dollars let's say if
they're calling you directly on your
website that's one up size your is the
billing rate another upside is you know
you're not paying for those leads in the
sense that you are Fiverr contact but
you are paying for the ads so and Google
AdWords can get quite expensive if you
go the route of your own website and
decide to promote it through a program
like Google Adwords
one thing I would strongly suggest is
avoid the various pay-per-click
management services that are out there
there are a lot of services out there
that say we'll manage your pay-per-click
for you and then they take a percentage
of your advertising budget for doing so
if you're paying for Adwords you can
actually call Google AdWords support and
they'll help you with any aspects of it
you want and there's plenty of tutorials
even on YouTube on how to use AdWords
effectively do not pay somebody to
manage that for you that just really
raises your advertising costs
exponentially so really the three
biggest ways just to sum up to get
business as a freelance developer go to
networking events third party platforms
and using your own website you're going
to do the networking route again don't
talk to other don't talk to other
developers talk to various business
owners and other individuals BNI is a
great way to do that again the link is
below third party platforms fiber
thumbtack upside of this lots of
potential business downside much smaller
profit margins your own website upside
of this is you're charging full price
for your work downside of this is you
are paying for advertising really just
pick any of these that you feel works
best for your situation and try a
combination you know like of all of them
so again when you connect with clients
through any of these platforms
make sure you employ the selling
techniques we talked about in the last
part of our video well this pretty much
sums it up in terms of a quick
discussion on how to make money as a
freelancer if you have any questions
just contact us directly